i've been playing ubisoft games for well
over a decade and i've covered quite a
few of them on the channel
in general i keep a close eye on any
news that comes out from this publisher
because it's an area of interest for me
so why not have some fun with it
this will be a little different to the
videos i usually make these won't be the
usual heavily scripted structured
monotone style that you used to not that
those videos are going anywhere i just
want to try something new you know for
my own sanity basically i'm just gonna
sit in my recording booth and talk to
myself and then crop out the pieces that
actually make sense
a news dump if you like
after almost a decade since the last
splinter cell game was released ubisoft
has finally announced that their toronto
studio is working on a splinter cell
remake
fans of the series myself included have
been screaming out for a new game for
years only to be disappointed
and while there has been a lot of rumors
about it becoming an open world luda
shooter they have been quick to stamp
this out
saying that what we're trying to do is
make sure that the spirit of the early
game remains intact in all of the ways
that gave the early splinter cell its
identity
that it will be kept linear like the
original games not open world
however this is in the very early stages
of development so it's unlikely we'll be
seeing any time in the next couple of
years
it's good to see that sam fisher will
finally stop being treated as simply a
marketing prop for dlcs and other games
the prince of persia sand of time remake
has been delayed
again
announced in september 2020 for a
january 2021 release we're now unlikely
to see it until sometime between april
1st 2022 and march 31st 2023
the remake of this 20 year old game has
seen a number of delays but the
development team did release a statement
reassuring people that the development
is still very much underway
the division heartland's delay wasn't
announced publicly but instead it was
found in ubisoft's latest quarterly
earnings report
when heartland was first announced back
in may of this year it was given a
release window of sometime either this
year or next
ubisoft then clarified it to a fiscal
2122 release meaning sometime between
april 2021 and march 2022
however the report has stated it will in
fact be releasing sometime between april
2022 and march 2023
but that's okay because there's a big
update coming to the division too soon
well
maybe not
earlier this month it was announced that
the eagerly anticipated title update
previously stated as february 2022 is
now to be released at a later date
they've said that they need just a
little extra time to allow them to
continue building towards their vision
for the future of the division ii and to
polish the core elements in the new game
mode season narrative and other new
features
as i've been saying for a while the
original team was effectively dismantled
and moved on to other projects after the
communication earlier this year that
effectively said they hadn't planned on
releasing any new content after the fei
lao manhunt
since then they've had to build a whole
new team as well as bringing in another
studio
i was expecting either a very small
update or delays
assassin's creed valhalla is getting
another dlc in march 2022
fans of the franchise must be stoked as
this is what the third major update
since the game was released a little
over a year ago
the dawn of ragnarok is said to be the
most ambitious expansion in franchise
history where either must embrace their
destiny as odin the norse god of battle
and wisdom
the dlc will add another 35 plus hours
to the story which is essentially
another game in its own right
[Music]
currently it's unclear how they plan to
wrap up valhalla and move on to the
already confirmed live service
assassin's creed infinity but given the
recent events of countless game delays
it's fairly likely they'll struggle to
have it released in the 2022 window they
originally gave
ubisoft certainly aren't afraid of
breaking the mould of what brought their
games to where they are today so it'll
be interesting to see what they have
planned for infinity all we really know
at this point is it looks to be set over
multiple periods of time and players
will be able to jump back and forth
between them
they've actually been surprisingly quiet
about it up until now
and finally this month ubisoft also
announced ubisoft quartz
using this platform they'll be bringing
the first nfts that are playable in a
aaa game
it is currently in beta so can only be
found in ghost recon breakpoint at this
stage
now i'm not going to go ahead and
explain what nfts are and what my
thoughts are around them that's a whole
video on its own
but i suggest you do a bit of reading up
and maybe watch some videos explaining
them from both sides of the fence
when you're done with that and you still
don't understand why these have any
place in gaming good it means you're a
well-rounded and logical person
summing quotes up if eligible you can
acquire items called digits
these are cosmetic items that are
wearable in-game
they are unique and limited edition
they feature an engraved serial number
they remember who owned them
and you can sell them on authorized
third-party marketplaces whenever you
feel like
sounds pretty good right
well not according to the overwhelming
majority of people who responded to this
including a large number of ubisoft
employees and developers
it isn't necessarily even nfts that a
lot of people are so opposed to it's
their position in gaming
i can see them having a part to play
outside of gaming in the future and
we're likely to see a lot more of them
albeit in a much different form than
what we're seeing today
it's that this particular situation is
done in such a blatantly obvious way for
executives to make more money and less
about adding any sort of entertainment
value
while the first items were free you'd be
kidding yourself if you think it will
always be this way
this is very much just a different form
of micro transactions
these two started as purely cosmetic but
over time we've seen a number of titles
go the way of pay to win
the problem with nfts is that they have
an even larger effect than all of the
other money-making systems since they
make exponentially more money than all
of them combined
people aren't upset about what it is now
it's more about what they can see it
becoming within the industry a slippery
slope where real world inequality could
start to affect players and game
experience
the exact thing a lot of people use
gaming to escape from
however regardless of the outcry from
the general gaming community ubisoft's
ceo has publicly stated that he just
doesn't care and that they will be
proceeding as planned and that this is
just the beginning
maybe i should just jump on the nft
bandwagon and create an nft from a
picture of my nipple or something though
my luck has probably already been stolen
and replicated into four or five hundred
different variations by now
i'm not sure how far i'll take these
monthly updates as far as the
controversy and things that pop up but
we'll just see how the following months
turn out
anyway thanks for watching and i'll
catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
you